[Música]
desde el pasado 22 de octubre diferentes
sectores sociales políticos y económicos
de Santa Cruz que es considerada la
locomotora económica de Bolivia
comenzaron una huelga que vuelve a dejar
en evidencia la polarización que vive
ese país suramericano y también dejan
evidencia esa división que hay entre la
zona del altiplano y la zona del oriente
del país esta huelga buscaba exigir al
presidente Luis Arce que adelante un año
es decir para que se ha realizado en
2023 el censo Nacional de población y de
vivienda que está previsto por el
gobierno para ser realizado en marzo del
2024 El empadronamiento Nacional de
población y vivienda se realizará el 23
de marzo de 2024 con base a estos
resultados preliminares se hará la
distribución de recursos en septiembre
de 2024 un mes antes de lo que habíamos
inicialmente propuesto convoco a todas
las corrientes democráticas de nuestro
país
y las que existe dentro del comité
interinstitucional a cerrar el paso a la
violencia y a los intentos de ruptura
del orden constitucional que algunas de
sus fracciones está llevando adelante
con este ascenso buscan hacer una
actualización sobre la cantidad de
habitantes que hay en el departamento y
de esta forma también pueden ampliar así
los recursos económicos que reciben
desde el gobierno central y también
ampliar la representación en el
parlamento boliviano estas jornadas de
protestas se han caracterizado por el
bloqueo de las principales vías de la
ciudad de Santa Cruz de la Sierra
también el cierre del funcionamiento
parcial de algunas actividades
económicas Pero por qué es importante
esto y que tenga lugar en el
departamento de Santa Cruz lo vamos a
ver los vamos a poner en contexto pues
Santa Cruz de la Sierra es la capital
del departamento de Santa Cruz es el
centro comercial de Bolivia es el
principal nú urbano del país con una
población de aproximadamente 2.3
millones de habitantes en la zona urbana
la ciudad de Santa Cruz puede alcanzar
hasta los 3 millones de habitantes es un
destacado centro Industrial agropecuario
forestal minero y de hidrocarburos es el
departamento que más aporta al producto
interno bruto de ese país de acuerdo con
la ley boliviana cada 10 años debe ser
realizado este censo de población y
vivienda sin embargo el presidente Arce
determinó que se mantiene como ustedes
ya lo oían en su decisión de realizar
este censo en marzo del 2024 Cuál es
Entonces el trasfondo de estas
manifestaciones porque el gobierno
insiste en hacer el censo en 2024 Cuáles
son los argumentos que hay de esos
reclamos Para volver a Bolivia también
un país Federal porque todo esto volvió
a quedar sobre la mesa a raíz de estas
manifestaciones ciudadanas y de
diferentes sectores en Santa Cruz Por
qué existen esos deseos de parte de la
región Oriental del país país de volver
el país un estado Federal el panorama
general de Bolivia a raíz de este mes de
manifestaciones o de protestas en Santa
Cruz es nuestro tema de análisis hoy en
France 24 para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a José Carlos Gutiérrez él es
diputado de creemos él se encuentra en
la ciudad de Santa Cruz de la Sierra
justamente y también está con nosotros
Daisy choque de ellas diputada del
movimiento al socialismo más que es el
partido oficialista y también se conecta
desde la ciudad de Santa Cruz de la
Sierra también allá en el Oriente
boliviano ustedes nuestros televidentes
Recuerden que también hacen parte de
esta discusión de este debate esta
conversación con todos sus comentarios y
preguntas que pueden dejar a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo y Recuerden que la
etiqueta es numeral el debate f24 para
que dejen todos sus comentarios no se
olviden también que todos los contenidos
del programa también están en diferentes
plataformas de podcast estamos en Apple
podcast en Spotify deezer y tuning
Bueno pues comienzo dándole la
bienvenida entonces a José Carlos que
fue el primer invitado que presenté para
el programa para conocer opiniones José
Carlos que deja este poco más de un mes
de manifestaciones en Bolivia raíz de
estas discrepancias en torno a la fecha
de realización de el censo de vivienda y
habitacional y de población allí en
Bolivia Cuál es su balance
Muchísimas gracias Santiago un saludo a
través de usted al mundo entero que nos
escucha ahora y por supuesto sigue la
sintonía de France 24 primero que Santa
Cruz determinó un paro indefinido
precisamente para que se dé una fecha
viable en el 2023 para que los
resultados del censo puedan ser
aplicables antes de las elecciones de El
2025 esto significa redistribución de
recursos y también redistribución de
escaños este tema ha sido dilatado por
supuesto por el gobierno la
responsabilidad es del presidente Arce
catacora ya que antes del decreto 48 24
que es el que usted ha mostrado en la
pantalla hubieron dos decretos también
anteriores el 45 46 que fijaba ya la
fecha para el 16 de noviembre de este
año
pasado unos cuantos días debido hacerse
el censo según decreto
45-46 luego el decreto 4760 que fue
aprobado por el 48 24 que es la actual y
que pone una fecha para el mes de marzo
la dilación la retardación de la
elaboración del censo tiene por supuesto
un contexto político para el gobierno
central el gobierno de Arce catacora
sabe y conoce de que el centralismo
maneja la economía y por supuesto el
Santa Cruz necesita saber cuántos son
dónde están Y con seguridad que podría
cambiar podría cambiar también
la redistribución de recursos y
retribución parlamentaria en Bolivia por
eso es que la lucha es fundamental
porque también debe existir una
planificación en el país y el
departamento que más produce y el
departamento que está frente a la cabeza
de la economía debe necesitar certezas
en ese sentido
Esa es la opinión de José Carlos
Gutiérrez vamos a ver que él nos dice la
diputada Daisy choque también Bienvenida
al programa diputada Gracias por estar
con nosotros se conecta también desde la
ciudad de Santa Cruz de la Sierra
diputada bienvenida Y qué deja este mes
de manifestaciones en Bolivia Cuál es el
análisis que hacen ustedes
cómo está un saludo cordial para todos
quienes Ven a esta hora el programa
France 24 no para nosotros es importante
también indicar de que desde un
principio ha habido una falta de
voluntad de poder buscar consensos y
soluciones para evitar este paro Cívico
nuestro gobierno nacional a través de la
comisión de autonomías ha convocado A
los nueve departamentos justamente para
poder analizar y en todo caso informar
lo que estaba sucediendo sin embargo
Santa Cruz no ha tenido su
representación que en este caso debería
haber sido el gobernador incluso después
de tantas reuniones de consenso y de
búsqueda de soluciones un día antes de
que inicie el paro Cívico claramente
establecía nuestro presidente de que se
garantizaba el censo para el mes de
abril se garantizaba la redistribución
económica pero sin embargo continuaron
las movilizaciones porque utilizaron
donde decían nosotros queremos el censo
2023 Sí o sí sin tomar en cuenta de que
podía garantizarse tanto la
redistribución económica como el tema
también de los escaños sin necesidad de
tener que adelantar el el censo en este
caso han habido tanto búsquedas de
consensos en reunión búsqueda de
acuerdos en el cual en muchas de ellas
no ha participado el gobernador Quién es
el directo responsable de participar y
de dar a conocer el punto de vista y
defender al departamento en este caso
han tenido la capacidad de defender
técnicamente
tu postura del Por qué el 2023 Entonces
no han tenido capacidad de consenso pero
tampoco de demostrar técnicamente del
Por qué Y cómo iban a hacer para reducir
los tiempos justamente quería
preguntarle eso diputada por qué cree
usted A qué se puede atribuir esta
insistencia del gobierno de Santa Cruz
de realizar este descenso en el 2023 y
no en el 2024 Cuál es el punto que
ustedes pueden ver allí
bueno acá hay que ser claro el señor
Luis Fernando Camacho Quien encabezó
toda la revuelta el cual ha cobrado
muchas vidas en el país en el 2019
lógicamente con la ayuda de su padre ex
militar que también compró a la policía
y a los militares en nuestro país hasta
poder tener el golpe hoy vio una
oportunidad de utilizar el censo como
una bandera política y a través de los
medios de comunicación y con apoyo de la
mala información y demás han logrado
hacer creer a la población de que el
gobierno central no estaba de acuerdo en
hacer el censo y no le dijeron nunca la
verdad de que sí se iba a hacer el censo
que se estaban adecuando los tiempos a
una realidad también para la
actualización cartográfica estadística
que en este caso Prácticamente solo un
municipio de todo el departamento de
Santa Cruz lo tenía avanzado entonces
hay una necesidad de búsqueda de
desestabilizar el país
económicamente para luego poder dar el
Salto a la desestabilidad política
buscando nuevamente dar un golpe de
estado en diputado Gutiérrez Cuál es su
impresión al respecto que responden
ustedes a este punto de vista sobre la
necesidad del gobierno de Santa Cruz o
esta insistencia a realizar el censo en
el 2023
mire empecemos primero porque el censo
debió darse vuelvo a repetir el 26 de
noviembre de este año el INE el
Instituto Nacional de estadística el
ministro de planificación estuvieron en
la cámara de diputados para pedir la
aprobación de un crédito de 140 millones
de dólares para el trabajo censal
acompañado de supuestos avances al 98%
para que se elabore el censo no se lo
hizo se lo reemplazó con otro decreto Y
eso significa de que quien está
mintiendo quien está dilatando este tema
es el gobierno con una intencionalidad
primero que podamos descubrir de una vez
por todas Cuántos somos dónde estamos y
cuál es la real representación política
que tiene actualmente el gobierno en ese
sentido porque
en nuestra consideración el más ha
venido utilizando un padrón electoral
abultado Y por supuesto el fraude del
2019 fue descubierto precisamente por la
manipulación electoral que hubo y Evo
Morales renunció no hubo tal golpe hay
una persecución política en Santa Cruz Y
por supuesto cuando se inicia el paro en
Santa Cruz hubo una provocación de parte
del gobierno primero no permitiendo las
exportaciones de las que vive el
departamento de Santa Cruz y por las que
trabaja en favor del país hubo
imposibilidad de tener acceso a la
gasolina y a la distribución de
combustible un cerco a Santa Cruz
encabezado por campesinos del movimiento
asocialismo del gobierno para generar
violencia y ustedes mostraba en las
pantallas la violencia con la que la
policía arremete en contra de las
personas que pacíficamente están
haciendo un paro voluntario que lleva 33
33 días y en ese sentido se quieren
esconder muchas cosas en lo político por
lo tanto todas las mesas técnicas que
propuso el gobierno fueron dilatorias
para qué Para que supuestamente Santa
Cruz secance terminó con este análisis
en el sentido de que esto tiene mucho
más que ver con un contexto
internacional en el que se mueve el
socialismo el movimiento al socialismo
es parte del foro de Sao Paulo e
internacionalmente como estamos un
programa que lo ve mucha gente tenemos
que contextualizar de que el socialismo
Por supuesto que quiere destruir la
economía de los países para empobrecerla
como la de provencieron en Cuba en
Venezuela y Nicaragua y en todos los
países y nada raro que más bien nos
hayan permitido estar más de 30 días
para que acabemos de una vez con la
economía productiva de este país y el
día de mañana este país quiebre
lo están quebrando precisamente y que
intencionalmente con el comunismo en el
mundo a través del foro Sao Paulo
diputada choque que dice usted ante
estas acusaciones de esta supuesta
persecución al departamento de Santa
Cruz por ser justamente un bastión
opositor al movimiento al socialismo el
más que es el partido oficialista
partido al que pertenece usted
imagínense utilizan ahora la bandera del
censo en su momento utilizaron la
bandera del fraude que nunca demostraron
Ellos tienen que ser conscientes que con
su agrupación Alianza o como quieran
llamarlo han logrado el 14% de la
población Perdón del voto en el 2020
Entonces no pueden querer pretender de
que con fraude con con cualquier
situación que se dé en el padrón
electoral el movimiento socialismo Ha
logrado el 55%. entonces tienen que
aceptar no más que no tuvieron apoyo del
pueblo boliviano por un lado por otro
lado
habla de persecución persecución es lo
que se ha sufrido el 2020 una vez que
ASUME la señora Yanina En complicidad
con Luis Fernando Camacho Rómulo calvo
los mismos actores que ahora han
encabezado estas movilizaciones
ha habido una persecución donde más de
1800 hemos tenido presos
miles y miles de perseguidos 37 muertos
miles de heridos no y ahora
vienen a hablar de persecución política
cuando ellos mismos están viendo y sabe
el Señor el diputado José Carlos de que
hace unas dos semanas han incendiado
nuestra federación sindical única de
trabajadores campesinos que representa a
los campesinos del departamento
hablan de que no había exportación o se
les cerró las exportaciones yo no
entiendo de qué exportaciones hablan si
ellos mismos han dicho que estamos en
paro
hablan de que faltaba gasolina pero no
que estábamos en paro
Lamentablemente estos señores
consideran al campesino como si por el
simple hecho de ser campesino Es
simplemente macista y no reconocen que
también es cruceño que también tiene
derecho de poder pensar también tiene
derecho de protestar ya que los hermanos
campesinos que estaban saliendo a las
ciudades son agredidos en cada uno de
los puntos de bloqueo y que no hablen de
un paro voluntario me da vergüenza o no
sé qué sentir cuando escucho decir paro
voluntario aquí lo que hay es un bloqueo
un bloqueo de los barrios un bloqueo a
las comunidades un bloqueo a los
municipios y por último hay un
autobloqueo que está obligando al
ciudadano cruceño a estar en un encierro
o un arresto domiciliario durante todo
este tiempo por qué no habla también de
todos los días que sea perjudicado el
estudiante que ahora prácticamente ya ha
terminado el año escolar y muchos de
nuestros estudiantes amedrentados en los
puntos de bloqueo porque no han podido
pasar en las movilidades en cuestión
cuando ha habido han tenido que
trasladarse a distancia la universidad
Lleva más de 30 días paralizados cuando
estamos acabando semestre y cuando se
está acabando una gestión estudiantil
que en este caso dos años hemos tenido
clases irregulares debido a la pandemia
y ahora Estamos perjudicándolo otra vez
un mes el país ha perdido el
departamento de Santa Cruz ha perdido
más de mil millones imagínense En qué
tiempo vamos a recuperar aquellos
Entonces no están midiendo las
consecuencias y se han dejado llevar por
un fanatismo de decir hoy nuevamente
Tenemos la oportunidad de agarrar esta
bandera y volver a generar
desestabilidad política y social en el
departamento diputado Gutiérrez qué tan
asfixiado está el departamento de Santa
Cruz y la ciudad de Santa Cruz de la
sierra con este mes de huelgas de
paralizaciones de funcionamiento a media
marcha
Gracias a que no ha habido una respuesta
concreta de parte del presidente Gracias
a todas las mentiras que nos hizo el
Instituto Nacional de estadística el
Ministerio de planificación Gracias a
que vinieron a la asamblea plurinacional
de diputados y senadores y le mintieron
diciendo de que el censo estaba
prácticamente planificado ya al 98% de
avance con cartografías boletas en sal y
todo lo que significaba la elaboración
del censo no se lo hizo este 26 de
noviembre pasado
o 16 de noviembre Disculpe 16 de
noviembre pasado y por supuesto el
gobierno de manera política ha llevado a
mesas técnicas que no tuvieron ningún
tipo de Avance en ese sentido la
población de Santa Cruz ha visto odio en
contra de el departamento de Santa Cruz
Y por supuesto hablo de persecución
política porque lo único que han sido
detenidos han sido jóvenes que
pertenecen a Santa Cruz que representan
a una oposición al gobierno mientras
malhechores delincuentes y hordas del
más han sido violentas en contra de la
población acompañada por la policía y ni
un solo preso ni un solo detenido ni
ningún tipo de investigación la policía
el otro día va clasificado una niña de
meses y hasta ahorita hasta ahora en
este momento no hay ningún tipo de
investigación y se ha rechazado la
denuncia de esa señora en contra de la
policía evidentemente la persecución
política no es de ahora viene desde el
2009 cuando han habido ejecuciones
extrajudiciales
acusando a este departamento de
separatismo ahora lo acusan de golpista
y la persecución política es real porque
la justicia también está postrada y
destruida gracias al movimiento
socialista no hay un del padrón
electoral y terminó con esto el gobierno
En definitiva Está siguiendo por
supuesto una lógica del foro de Sao
Paulo para quebrar de una vez por todas
la economía y obviamente tenernos en la
pobreza para que estemos como Venezuela
como Cuba o Nicaragua diputado Gutiérrez
pero es afirmación de querer destruir la
economía y sobre todo la economía de
Santa Cruz que como presentaba yo al
inicio del programa pues es la
locomotora económica del país Esto no es
pegarse un tiro en el pie justamente
necesitan los recursos para mantener
esos programas sociales que son las
banderas de estos partidos
socialistas o de izquierda en América
Latina qué sentido tiene que el propio
presidente Arce destruya la economía del
motor económico del país
qué sentido habrá tenido para Venezuela
destruir su propia economía y la
economía más floreciente de todo
Sudamérica qué sentido tendría para
Argentina destruir prácticamente su
economía y la exportación de carne y
todas las exportaciones que tenía
Argentina con el kirchnerismo qué
sentido tendría para Lula
hacer lo que hizo con Brasil y por
supuesto con con el con Ecuador con Perú
como lo están haciendo ahora Ese es el
sentido que tiene el comunismo
empobrecer a a sus países quebrarlo
desnudarlo y obviamente tenerlo postrado
a una dictadura
camuflada de democracia siendo
socialista le voy a hacer recuerdo a la
diputada choque con esto termino de
verdad el presidente Arce ha dicho
públicamente que quiere ser como Cuba
estamos yendo en realidad a ser como
Cuba y Ese es su sueño lo ha dicho que
dice la diputada choque Cuál es su
opinión
primero que hay que aclarar Que aquí hay
una lucha de clases y cuando él menciona
lo que pasó en Venezuela lo que pasó en
Argentina lo que pasó en Brasil nos
vamos dando cuenta claramente de que
ellos vienen haciendo lo mismo que
hicieron los capitalistas en estas
regiones imagínense el departamento de
Santa Cruz a la cabeza de estos señores
fascistas separatistas y demás Cuánto
dinero ha perdido y ellos que manejan el
discurso de que nos vamos a convertir en
Venezuela durante más de 15 años no hoy
en un mes convierten al país no voy a
decir como en Venezuela porque no
conozco su idiosincrasia no conozco la
situación pero es que han convertido a
Santa Cruz en un departamento miserable
donde en algunos lugares Ya ni se
encuentra
alimento porque no les permiten pasar se
ha convertido en algo donde se vulnera
el derecho constitucional de las
personas ya que los puntos de bloqueo
que aparte que te cobran en cada uno de
los puntos y
cierto puntos de bloqueo donde hay dos
tres personas bloqueando con una Pita
pero que también te cobran a cada 100
metros en cada cuadra imagínate Cuánto
tiene que pagar una persona que va en
motocicleta y más aún si va en automóvil
Entonces
se está vulnerando los derechos a la
salud ya que hay muchos enfermos que no
pueden cruzar los puntos sin ser
amedrentados sin Ver actos de violencia
racimos discriminaciones ahora dice Por
qué no dicen ellos el ataque que hacen a
las zonas que supuestamente según ellos
son masistas el plan 3000 ha sido sujeto
de
avasallamiento de estas hordas violentas
criminales a la cabeza de la unión
juvenil cruceñita que noche tras noche
les quitan el sueño a la población y
cuestionan porque aparece la policía a
poner orden Entonces qué tiene que hacer
la policía dejar que sigan saqueando los
mercados dejar que sigan quemando las
casetas dejar que sigan agrediendo a
nuestras mujeres y a nuestros hermanos
indígenas originarios campesinos han
tenido el descaro y la sinvergüenzura de
quemar nuestra sede sindical indígena
hemos visto sus gobernadores agarrando
chicotes para waskear a nuestras mujeres
indígenas entonces aquí hay una muestra
Clara de lo que ellos quieren hacer
quienes ahogar la economía del
departamento y del país para luego decir
que los gobiernos progresistas llevan al
fracaso económico a sus países
diputada y diputado Gutiérrez otro tema
que ha quedado aquí sobre la mesa y que
vuelve a traer mucha polémica en Bolivia
es este tema de la autonomía el tema del
federalismo y también muchos ya hablan y
vuelven a poner sobre la mesa la
independencia del departamento de Santa
Cruz este poder económico siempre ha
sido esa carta de juego para las
autoridades cruceñas a la hora de
sentarse a negociar por cualquier tipo
de tema con las autoridades centrales si
se respetan las autonomías en Bolivia si
lo que está estipulado de acuerdo a la
ley que dice el diputado Gutiérrez
Muchas gracias la reivindicación cruceña
Data de siglos En 1877 el gobierno
central asesina a Andrés Ibáñez lo
persigue por más de 500 kilómetros lo
matan y matan a 10 personas más
tildando no dice paratistas en 1877
Santa Cruz ha sufrido por hordas del
gobierno central del andinocentrismo con
los ukureñas en en
1970 y algo con los ukureñas Diez mil
personas entraron a Santa Cruz y
masacraron a los jóvenes que pedían el
la la aplicación de la ley del 11% que
hacía 20 años estaba durmiendo aquí en
la paz en contra de Santa Cruz La
reivindicaciones cruceña son permanentes
y es la de Santa Cruz en la historia de
lucha contra el centralismo por lo tanto
nosotros el 13 de noviembre se hizo un
Cabildo y ese Cabildo llegó a tener más
de dos millones de personas concentradas
en el Cristo Redentor y han propuesto
cinco cinco cinco preguntas a las que le
dijeron sí entre una una de ellas es
precisamente darnos la potestad a los
legisladores para que elaboremos un
proyecto de ley que garantice el censo
en el país y otra también que delega al
comité una convocatoria a una comisión
constitucional para que revise nuestra
relación como Santa Cruz con respecto a
Bolivia Sí y el punto cuatro que también
establece de que si no se unen
formalmente los demás departamentos a
esta lucha vamos a asumir por propia
cuenta nuestras reivindicaciones y en
ese trabajo estamos Daisy es cruceña
Daisy sabe de que el modelo productivo
cruceño ha sido
denostado prácticamente por el gobierno
central y obviamente Santa Cruz No va a
parar Aunque el centralismo quiera y
obviamente Ese es el reto que ahora
Santa Cruz ha puesto prácticamente en el
tapete a la luz de el mundo y Bolivia
diputada choque entonces es posible ver
un futuro de una Bolivia Federal
digamoslo así si se le puede llamar De
esta forma como lo vi usted es que son
tan contradictorios no cuestiona
Venezuela cuando Venezuela es un estado
federal y ahora quieren llevar a Santa
Cruz a supuestamente hacer igual o a
Bolivia a ser igual que una Venezuela
que están cuestionada por ellos no es
lamentable ver sus contradicciones en
2008 se luchaba por las autonomías
nuestra Constitución habla de las de las
autonomías sin embargo ellos cuestionan
el centralismo de estado sin embargo
tenemos en Santa Cruz el centralismo
departamental hoy por un su gobernador
no maneja un presupuesto y tampoco es
elegido democráticamente ellos definen y
hay derasos nosotros queremos decirle si
bien el diputado José Carlos menciona de
que yo soy de Santa Cruz pero soy de una
región al cual ellos llegado el momento
no reconocen como Santa Cruz Simplemente
nos dicen masistas no entienden que
también pertenecemos al departamento de
Santa Cruz nosotros en nuestras regiones
estamos trabajando las autonomías
regionales y vamos a consolidar las
regiones porque Santa Cruz de la Sierra
tiene que entender que es grande es
fuerte gracias a las regiones los cuales
Siempre están siendo de manera
permanente atropellados porque pareciera
que cruceños solo son quienes pertenecen
a la provincia Andrés Ibáñez Entonces
estamos planteando la autonomía regional
en el norte la autonomía regional en el
sur la autonomía regional en el oeste y
queremos ver que el gobierno
departamental
siga manteniendo esa postura que
mantiene ahora queremos que la economía
ya no llegue a la gobernación porque ahí
utilizan nuestro dinero para las joyas
comunes utilizan para comprar vándalos a
mandar a golpear a nuestra gente vamos a
pedir que el dinero que tiene que llegar
al departamento vaya distribuido de
manera directa a las regiones para
atender sus necesidades claro Entonces
si no hemos podido consolidar una
autonomía verdadera dentro del
departamento me parece una vergüenza
querer ahora utilizar otra bandera con
otro nombre que quieren Llamar el
federalismo diputado Gutiérrez también
parte de los reclamos que hace desde
Santa Cruz es el aumento del centralismo
por parte del gobierno del presidente
Arce usted coincide con esa idea que ha
habido un aumento del centralismo
justamente para presionar a Santa Cruz
en estos temas políticos y sobre todo
por el tema económico
lo está declarando la diputada Daisy
choque divide y
gobernarás precisamente el gobierno ha
dividido la autonomía en cuatro
autonomía regional municipal
departamental y la autonomía indígena es
autonomía prácticamente
se ha
posibilitado el debilitamiento de las
autonomías como tal para re centralizar
los recursos le dan competencias a cada
municipio le dan competencias a la
gobernaciones pero sin embargo no
generan un pacto fiscal hasta ahora que
debió hacerse hace hace más de 10 años
en ese sentido nosotros como Santa Cruz
tenemos Clara la figura y en ese sentido
también vamos a seguir luchando por
reivindicaciones económicas sociales y
por supuesto que tengan que ver también
con mayor libertad democracia asegurando
que este país no vuelva como Venezuela
ni Cuba y obviamente no le vamos a dar
paso al comunismo en ese sentido por lo
tanto esta lucha va a seguir Y por
supuesto ahora y acaban de decirnos que
hay la sesión plenaria A las 6 de la
tarde en estos minutos se va a instalar
y de mañana Disculpen de mañana se va a
instalar mañana para que precisamente
aseguremos a través de una ley y es lo
que se está trabajando en una comisión
la diputada también es proponente de un
proyecto de ley para consensuar
evidentemente una ley que asegure el
censo pareciera muy muy muy muy ilógico
para el mundo para lo que nos ven que un
país se quiebre se pelee y resista tanta
tanto problema por la elaboración de un
censo cuando en realidad Debería ser
normal Algo ahí detrás Y hay un cálculo
político para no realizarlo eso queda a
la vista y por supuesto nosotros como
cruceño vamos a tener en cuenta el
mandato de más de dos millones de
personas vuelvo a repetir para
revisar la futura relación con este país
porque así lo mandó el Cabildo Y también
vamos a asumir nuestra propia
reivindicaciones en ese sentido con
seguridad que nos van a seguir
persiguiendo y vuelvo a repetir la
historia de Santa Cruz en la historia de
lucha cívica en contra de un centralismo
boliviano Que prácticamente no tienen
favorecido desde que nacimos
diputada su opinión a estos argumentos
fíjense la postura que asumen no dicen
les damos 72 horas para que se sumen a
nuestra lucha imagínense querer sublevar
a los demás departamentos y que por la
fuerza se tenían que sumar porque eso lo
han dicho en el Cabildo ahora dice
divide y vencerás no no es una cuestión
de divide y vencerás estamos cansados
las regiones que Santa Cruz de la Sierra
se crea dueño de todas las regiones la
región del Norte La aporta con todo lo
que es referente a lo productivo y
granelero la zona oeste le aporta con
granos y ganaderías
la zona de la región de la Cordillera le
aporta con el idh por los hidrocarburos
Yo me pregunto no con el maltrato que
nos dan a las regiones con la falta de
respeto que hay por los campesinos que
viven en cada una de las provincias y
Ellos hablan de querer considerar su
relación con el estado central pues
nosotras los regiones queremos también
poner en consideración nuestra región
nuestras regiones
en consideración
con lo referente a lo que significa el
centralismo departamental Sí porque todo
ingresa allí y nunca vemos obras dentro
de nuestros municipios dentro de
nuestras regiones hay un total de
descuido Y hoy lo que ha sucedido con el
tema del paro Cívico No es otra cosa que
una cortina de humo para tapar la falta
de gestión de su líder al cual tanto
idolatran nuestros colegas diputa y
también la población cruceña porque
pareciera que aquel que habla más fuerte
y aquel que golpea a otro compañero
pareciera que ese fuera más cruceño y no
es así me quedan ya un par de minutos
para finalizar el programa diputados les
agradezco entonces que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que va a seguir en
qué va a terminar esta historia
veo que ambas partes están muy decididas
y y con un Norte muy claro de lo que
quieren lograr desde sus
reivindicaciones políticas que viene
entonces para Santa Cruz y que viene
Para Bolivia a raíz de esta coyuntura
generada por la realización de este
censo muy puntual por favor comienzo
entonces con el diputado Gutiérrez y
para el cierre dejó a la diputada choque
desde Santa Cruz vamos a desmantelar el
centralismo vamos a seguir
con nuestra ruta
dada ya en el Cabildo de más de dos
millones de personas que prácticamente
la suma de voluntades por Santa Cruz
para que tengamos un Norte totalmente
diferente sin olvidar que el movimiento
al socialismo violó la Constitución se
pasó por encima de un referéndum cometió
fraude y sigue en el poder
despilfarrando plata 250 mil millones de
dólares se gastaron los macistas y
seguimos pobres y nos prometieron Suiza
choque para el cierre su conclusión
bueno Primero que nada Nosotros tenemos
el objetivo de aprobar esa ley para
demostrarle al pueblo cruceño de que el
censo no ha sido otra cosa más que una
bandera para abrir la puerta a hablar de
federalismo o hablar de la relación del
departamento de Santa Cruz con el estado
no Yo me pregunto si el diputado José
Carlos ha analizado de que nosotros las
regiones también somos Santa Cruz y
también tenemos derecho a decidir cómo
queremos es Qué tipo de estado queremos
tener no Por lo tanto creo que hoy lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es aprobar
una ley en el cual ellos están
obstaculizando y ni entre ellos se ponen
de acuerdo Porque lastimosamente han
presentado cuatro proyectos de ley el
cual nos ha [__] y nos ha seguido
dilatando nosotros Entonces vamos a
seguir trabajando y Esperamos que mañana
a las 8 de la mañana tengo entendido que
se va a Reinstalar la sesión de la
comisión
constitucional a probar el proyecto de
ley y demostrar al pueblo cruceño que no
han sido otra cosa que utilizar para
otros intereses intereses separatistas
fascistas que tienen estos señores
diputados Muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros se nos acaba el
tiempo gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de frases 24 ustedes Gracias
por su sintonía sigan con nosotros
[Música]